I'm here with Cameron Pittman, who's
a course developer here at Udacity.
Thank you so much for
talking to me today.
>> Yeah, happy to be here.
>> So Cameron's here to talk about
some use of games in education.
And so I know you did something really
cool back when you taught in high school
with games in your
high school classroom.
So can you tell us
a little bit about that?
>> Sure.
So I was teaching high school physics,
and I realized I wanted
a better lab simulator.
It's really hard to find
lab supplies sometimes and
it's sometimes a lot easier
to use something virtual.
So I decided to use a video game,
because they're easily accessible and
readily available.
And I wound up using the video
game Portal 2 to teach physics.
Portal Two has a puzzle maker in it.
And this puzzle maker makes it really,
really easy to make a level
in about five minutes.
It really is so simple that even
somebody who has never even really used
a computer before can figure it out.
All you need to use is click and
drag and maybe one or two clicks, and
you actually have a full-blown level.
And because the game is
essentially a physics puzzle game,
the game itself follows
the laws of physics.
So what I had my students doing
is building levels in the game
that were essentially experiments.
And then I had them running experiments,
collecting data, and
then comparing the data they were
collecting to what they would expect to
see in the real world.
Which was pretty cool.
It was pretty wild.
We wound up doing about
ten labs in the class.
We did everything from
simple momentum and
motion to kinetic energy,
potential energy.
We even did some thermodynamics in
the game, which is pretty wild.
Because the laws of physics hold up
that well, that essentially we could
throw a bunch of objects bouncing off of
each other into a level, and it kind of,
sort of followed the laws of
thermodynamics, which is amazing.
We had some other cool ones
with terminal velocity.
And, yeah, I just had my
students comparing what they saw
to what they would see
in the real world.
And it wound up being a really,
really fun semester.
>> Yeah, I bet.
I bet they really got
a kick out of that.
So for any of our students who
might develop games to be used
in the classroom.
What do you need to think
about when you're developing
games to the classroom?
Make sure they're really a learning
experience and not a distraction for
the students, or just something they
kind of have fun playing around with,
and don't learn anything from?
>> Sure well it's important to remember
that games are a means to an end and
just one tool amongst many that
teachers have at their disposal.
So I think the idea here is just simply
make sure that the game, like the fun
mechanics of the game, are teaching
what you want students to learn.
So I kind of saw using Portal
as a way to engage students.
Because immediately you're using
a video game which is new and
different that students aren't familiar
with, normally in a classroom.
But they love outside of the classroom,
so I had their attention and
that's half the battle
in a physics class.
I was really happy about that.
And then the other thing that I
was really happy about is that
the actual mechanics of the game,
reflected exactly what I wanted
students to be learning at that time.
So there are a number of ways that you
can make an educational game just awful.
For instance, you could create let's say
a fighting game, a beat them up game.
But instead of getting a new life at the
end of the level you have to solve some
math problems and
then you get a new life.
That's silly.
That's dumb.
That's just a big distraction.
What you would want to do instead is
create a game maybe like Dragonbox.
Have you ever heard of that one?
>> I have not, no.
>> Oh it's awesome,
it's an algebra game.
And it's essentially,
it looks like a card game, but
it follows the laws of algebra.
You have to put cards in certain places,
and
what you're really doing there
is having fun with fractions,
and cross multiplying, and
it's actually a ton of fun.
And it's not a distraction, whatsoever.
Because the actual fun game
mechanic is teaching algebra.
>> Huh.
Very interesting.
Now the one thing that I feel it's
worth noting though, is that there
are those in the education community
which, and just for full disclosure,
I am one of them, that are often dubious
about the usage of games in education.
Mostly because many of us think
that it's really important to make
the material appealing in-and-of itself.
That if we have to put a game on it,
we've kind of already
fought a losing battle.
And now, when they move on to a class
that doesn't use games, they're just
going to tune out, because I'm used
to learning being very engaging and
fun because there was
a game attached to it.
And now I don't learn in the real world.
What would you say to people like me
who have that criticism about this?
That doesn't sound like that applies to
the Portal 2 thing but for other games,
what would you say to that?
>> I understand that concern.
I love physics and
I think physics in and
of itself should be super interesting.
Same thing with basically all science or
engineering in tech.
But for instance if I were
learning let's say I don't know,
what didn't I like in school?
I liked all my classes.
>> [LAUGH] You're not
the target audience for this.
>> [LAUGH] But
I think it's just one tool of many.
If it's a distraction, and
if it takes away from the fun or
the essence, of the material itself.
You're probably just
using the game wrong.
It's a tool like anything else.
It's just another media form.
You have videos, you have books you
have audio, these are all very valid and
relevant media sources to learn
anything and now you have games.
Games are just another way
to interact with material.
So despite the fact that normally
they are associated with fun and
they could potentially be distracting.
If used in the right way I think
there's really nothing to fear there.
>> I think you're getting at
a really important distinction,
which is between using games for
education and game-ifying education,
which are two very different things.
When we attach these badges and
things like that to education
it can apply some motivators.
But they're really extrinsic motivators,
which might not get to the heart of
what we really want to do in education.
Do you have any final thoughts for our
students who might be looking at doing
a game for their class project here?
>> You should go for it.
It's fun.
It's so much fun, and when you see kids'
eyes light up, when you see them get
really excited about playing a game, and
feel motivated to solve the kind of
problems that you want them to solve.
That's awesome, it's great.
It's a fantastic feeling, but at the end
of the day, it's just a lot of fun.
I mean,
you're adding fun to the classroom.
And there's really no reason that
learning can't be super enjoyable for
everybody involved.
So I say go for it.
Have a good time.
>> Cool.
Well thank you so
much for talking to us.
>> Yeah.
>> And have a great rest of your day.
>> Happy to be here.
Thanks.